all right so thanks for the introduction
my name is Sandeep
I'm pH
student co-advised by such an Cuddy and
Marco pavani and today I'll be
discussing distributed perception and
learning between robots in the cloud so
in other words how can
resource-constrained robots such as
low-power drones use cloud computing
services to improve their computer
vision task performance so today we're
starting to see fleets of networked
robots and these fleets of robots range
from low power delivery drones all the
way up to much larger self-driving
vehicles and these networked robots are
starting to face two coupled challenges
so first they're measuring growing
volumes a very rich sensory data so you
can see on the top left of the screen an
example of a lidar point cloud which is
used to localize different objects of
interest during navigation but coupled
with lidar autonomous vehicles also have
several HD cameras to do video streaming
and object detection and computer vision
tests so this is an example actually
from Stanford on my commute where you
can see HD video it's used to do object
detection and computer vision tasks but
also semantic segmentation so you can
cluster different objects of interests
that share the same label or category so
essentially to deal with this very rich
sensory stream and vantage point of the
physical world from multiple different
cameras robots are returning to
increasingly compute and power-hungry
models so in the case of computer vision
they might use deep neural networks and
a big trend in the art of deep learning
is people are turning to very large
models with several layers that are slow
for inference but also compute hungry
but very accurate so my thesis focuses
on how network connectivity can actually
help robots so if you go back to this
example of a fleet of low powered drones
they may see very rich sensory data and
to deal with this sensory data they may
have a local nominal robot model so in
the case of computer vision this could
be an object detection model called
mobile net that's very compute and power
efficient to run and it could actually
run in your smartphone for example but
it's not the most accurate so suppose
this drone is nominally uncertain for a
high level of sensing task then it might
send or what's called offload this image
of interest to the cloud so the cloud
could be a group of central servers or
it can actually be an edge computing
server so people are talking about 5g
networks in the future in your cell
tower you could actually have very good
compute to query very large deep
learning models that are compute
intensive so it doesn't end there in the
cloud you can access precomputed Maps or
databases say google images but also use
human annotation services or ask for
help for example so the prime benefit of
network connectivity in robotics is on
better real-time inference results
before computer vision so that will be
the first half of this talk but if you
look at so that will be a distributed
inference problem but if you look at a
different class of autonomous vehicles
say self-driving cars they may not
actually be compute or power limited so
they may have a very good bulky GPU on
board but still network connectivity can
actually help them profoundly so this
comes in the form of better specialized
models so robots can actually send
interesting field data to the cloud you
can actually retrain models and adapt
them to a robot's real time operating
conditions so it's estimated that future
self-driving cars will generate 4
terabytes a very rich sensory data in
just an hour and a half so even if a
fraction of this was sent to the cloud
you can retrain models and improve
computer vision task performance so that
problem of distributed learning will be
the second half of this talk so the key
challenge here is you're using very
precious system resources stemming from
congested network transfer up to human
annotation time cloud storage as well as
cloud computing time and you need to
split this across several different
robots in the fleet so this is the main
challenge of this field which is called
robotics so again this field cloud
robotics comes with some key challenges
that are typically understated today so
let's go back to the first problem of
distributed inference in real time
between say a low powered drone and a
cloud computing server so here the
problems are actually quite intuitive
first you have to wait some time for
network communication so that's the
first problem of network latency but
that's actually coupled with the slower
inference time of using a larger deep
neural net that's sitting in the cloud
and if you look at the second problem of
distributed learning as I mentioned
before there's a lot of data about 4
terabytes per car in just one and a half
hours so even if a fraction of this was
sent to the cloud from every robot say
every Tesla it takes some time to upload
it takes some time to annotate
interesting examples it adds to cloud
storage cost and to retrain models so
these are end to end or holistic systems
costs that need to be well mitigated so
the key theme of my research is to limit
communication so if we selectively but
judiciously queried the cloud we can get
the benefits of cloud computing and
robotics but with minimal end-to-end
systems costs ok so as I mentioned the
first half of this talk will be on a
problem of distributed inference so
real-time computer vision between a
robot and the cloud and this is an
offloading problem so let's actually
make this a bit more detailed so if you
go back to this fleet of drones they may
see a nominal scene of interest and here
I've actually computed the object
detection using Google's edge TPU or
tensor processing unit so it's an
dedicated AI accelerator running in the
USB stick that's very fast and compute
efficient it's a very new product so in
30 milliseconds you can localize the
major object in the scene which is a
human but clearly you can see there many
different objects of interests that are
totally missed by this shallow model so
maybe you can query the cloud if you're
uncertain and for the very same image
you see many more detection
especially for far-off objects so but
this incurs some delay of actually
querying this cloud computing server
coupled with the slower inference time
so the main contribution of our work is
this offloading logic which is a very
concise and small neural network that's
running on a drone that decides at every
time step whether a robot should use a
fast responsive local model or it's
highly uncertain and really needs the
accuracy benefits of cloud computing
okay and in the second half of this talk
I'll actually build upon distributed
inference in a very intuitive way
so if robots are already sending on
certain images to the cloud can't you
actually use them to retrain computer
vision models and improve their
performance in a nightly process for
example so this is a problem of
distributed learning and sampling
interesting training data from robots so
if we go back to this example again your
robotic fleets see very interesting data
during the course of a day so these are
all pictures from my commute to Stanford
so you me may see a very well understood
se freeway scene but then you may come
across a new construction site with
dynamic obstacles and roadblocks so this
is actually near the dish and finally
you may see a novel visual concept that
maybe your neural networks don't see but
don't understand currently such as the
way Moe car
so today's naive solutions would store
all of this data on board a robot and
actually this could overrun storage on
very small resource constrained robots
and then you'd spend quite a lot of time
uploading this over the network you'd
add to a terabyte size data set that's
growing daily
then you'd spend a fraction of time a
spent some time labeling even a fraction
of this data but then you could retrain
a model which takes cloud computing
resources what the benefit of this
process is you can sync back an improved
model to the robot for better
performance during the next field test
for example so what I'll show is you can
build a lightweight sampling algorithm
that's actually very similar to the off
loader it's sitting on a
resource-constrained robot that decides
maybe you should filter out the somewhat
boring well understood trading data keep
the interesting trading data so that you
can still get the benefits of retraining
a model but with minimal end-to-end
systems costs stemming from the network
but actually culminating in cloud
computing time so this is a problem of
intelligent sampling and they build upon
each other okay so at this time I can
give an outline for my talk so I'll
start with a motivation about using
cloud computing in robotics in the
context of using these deep neural
networks and then I'll actually switch
to a physical network which is the
wireless network and the costs of
streaming this high bitrate sensory data
to the cloud
I'll describe these two problems that
build upon each other and then I'll end
with future directions in network
control so the first question of
interest is what is the accuracy gap
between a robot model and the cloud
model is there actually some benefit of
actually using cloud computing and
robotics okay so to answer this question
we should understand some real very
recent trends in an in embedded AI so on
the Left pane you see a video that's
being processed by the Google edge
tensor processing unit so it's a
lightweight USB stick and it's running
at 70 frames per second but just a
couple years ago I would be stuck with
this generic arm CPU and it's going at
an order of magnitude slower so clearly
the capability of embedded AI for these
low-power drones is becoming faster
cheaper and more power efficient but in
France latency is not the only figure of
Merit what you care about is a relative
accuracy gap between a robot model and a
cloud model okay so I showed this
picture before and you can see that
these cloud grade models couldn't
clearly localize far off objects much
better and if you look across a very
large data set there's actually a
fundamental trade-off in the size of a
neural network which is the last column
so how many layers and parameters the
network has with the inference time so
how slow it is for one image
in France latency and the accuracy so
the accuracy metric here is the M AP or
the mean average precision so it's
saying how close is a bounding box to
the ground truth
coupled with did I get the label correct
and a general rule of thumb is these
cloud grade models which are in the
bottom row are an order of magnitude
larger and slower but double the
accuracy and you can see here there are
actually economic trade-offs so let's
say I have the money for just to cloud
GPUs maybe I can actually be running one
in your future cell tower and with the
money for the other GPU I'll actually
provision ten lightweight drones with
edge CPUs and they'll be using both
computations seamlessly
alright so robots shouldn't be stuck
with just a left model but should have
the best of both worlds algorithmically
so we can actually make this more clear
through actually footage from my dash
cam and my commute so again this is near
the dish and there's a very large
construction site for over six months at
Stanford and I collected quite a lot of
data here so you can see at the end of
this video or towards the end you
actually see an excavator or a tractor
and on the left you see the compute
efficient model which is mobile net and
it actually takes nine seconds longer to
localize this chapter because it needs
to get very close but on the right panel
you see that a cloud grade model can see
it from the get goes from initially so
an ideal solution would actually
interleave both computations so in query
the cloud server and say hey there's
actually a far-off tractor be where and
then track it efficiently on device so
let's actually watch this video so you
can see only nine seconds later it
realizes hey indeed there's an excavator
here but on the right panel with a very
stable bounding box you localize this
using a more computer intensive machine
learning model so robots can actually
have the best of both worlds
algorithmically and I'll show that next
so at this point at the talk I've
actually motivated there's actually some
benefit of using cloud computing and
robotics
the context of using a deep neural net
but what are the costs so what are the
costs of getting to the cloud so can we
actually experimentally quantify these
costs so some of these costs are very
intuitive to us we already know that we
always have very congested wireless
links you have problems with video
streaming well maybe at home or on the
move but if we dig deeper there are
actually more nuanced reasons for this
so our cellular networks today are built
asymmetrically so there's limited
capacity to stream to the cloud so
uplink as opposed to download which we
typically do today and the second reason
is actually quite interesting today's
video streaming protocols are
fundamentally designed for human
perception so they assume the downstream
consumer is the human eye so they want
to faithfully reconstruct every single
pixel in the scene so imagine a world
where most video that's actually sent
over the Internet is never watched by
the human eye or your eye but actually
by a deep neural network or a robot you
could actually crop out or automatically
learn what are the salient parts of an
image send much less over-the-air but
get the same sensing task accuracy so if
you're interested in this problem we
have a very small vision paper in the
networking community about this it's
about neural networks meeting physical
or wireless networks so we wanted to
test this problem of streaming to the
cloud out experimentally for another
sensing modality of interest in robotics
which is lidar so you could do a very
simple example actually at a home or at
Stanford so this actually comes from
Marcos class where they have several
robots and many students have were
streaming data from say Bella dine lidar
sensors to a central server but the
general idea is you have a lot light our
sensor and an embedded GPU and you can
stream these large point clouds to a
central server to do computation and the
question is how well can you do this
using today's default autonomy stack and
robotics which is Ross or the robot
operating system so if I send light our
point clouds to a server
they're actually fairly large they come
at 70 megabits per second which could be
handled by today's Wi-Fi networks so
let's see how this actually pans out
using Ross so at the source in blue as
expected you're sending steadily at 70
megabits per second but as I connect
more robots and actually increase
congestion on the network from right to
left you see some very puzzling results
so you can see in purple that if you
just send from two robots simultaneously
a single robot seems less than half the
data it was intended to see so this may
be puzzling at first but if you look
carefully ross was built and very
somewhat antiquated python code for at
least this part so it's not built for
high performance networking or streaming
so you could fix that or unlike video
which i showed on the previous slide
there are not well-established standards
for compression and streaming of lidar
streams so you could spend several years
to build a standard it actually took us
several years in industry to do this for
video streaming but what I'll propose is
a very simple algorithmic solution so if
you can learn to be intelligent about
what computation you do on the robot but
selectively query the cloud you can get
the benefit to both worlds but with
limited network bandwidth utilization so
this is a problem that's not talked
about much in robotics but actually
practitioners online are facing these
problems okay so at this point I've
motivated the benefits of using cloud
computing but the costs so let's
actually build this inference platform
so again this problem of real-time
computer vision is how a robot can
seamlessly integrate both local and
cloud computation so the main
contribution of our work is to view
cloud offloading as a problem of
sequential model selection under
uncertainty so I'll show how you can
build this offloading neural network
that's sitting on a robots embedded GPU
and deciding at every time step whether
it should use a fast responsive local
compute model or it's highly uncertain
and needs the cloud and I'll show
actually that this offloading neural
network is
18 times smaller than even mobile net
here and it's extremely fast for
real-time inference so how do we build a
system well to first understand how you
can mathematically characterize this
problem you can actually view offloading
as a problem of sequential model
selection and actually an optimal
control problem under uncertainty
so let's see why so let's take a very
simple example of streaming face
recognition from video so here the goal
is I want to localize every single human
face here and say who the person is so
if I see a news free frame of video I
may want to use my nominal robot model
but then on the very next frame of video
there's a lot of temporal coherence so
those faces will persist
so rather than drain power by running my
robot model once again I can just use
past predictions that I've saved in
memory then finally as the video
continues if I see someone totally new
then maybe I want to query the cloud so
this action of querying the cloud
actually comes with a fundamental
constraint and a limit suppose every
robot has a fair share they can only
query the cloud say 5% of the time then
given this budget but also uncertainty
about what the robot will see in the
future it needs to be smart about
whether I should really query the cloud
and this limits the bandwidth
utilization across the fleet so the goal
of this decision-making process is to
choose an optimal action which is what
is the right model to use currently
based on robots real-time uncertainty
and operating conditions so ideally you
want to use past predictions which are
very fast they could be potentially
stale however so if I'm somewhat
uncertain I may want to create the robot
model with this drain some power but
it's more accurate but then if I'm
filing finally highly uncertain I really
want to query the cloud but this
decrements my budget by one so I have
limited room to query the cloud in the
future when I might be really uncertain
so the state space in this problem
guides what is the right action to
choose at every time point so I'll make
this much more precise mathematically on
the next slide what the ideas are very
intuitive
ideally I want to know how much is a
sensory input changing so notice here
I'm showing the difference between two
successive frames of video most of the
backgrounds not changing and that's why
it's black so if the video is not
changing much I may want to use past
predictions but they could be old and
then if I want to query the cloud I need
to know what budget remains and how much
time do I have to allocate it and that's
about it and the goal of this
decision-making procedure is you want to
maximize accuracy but at the very same
time minimize the cost and latency of
quitting these different models so it
turns out it's very hard to model the
dynamics of a wireless network but also
what the robot will see in the future so
how the video evolves so we turn to
model free learning methods for control
specifically deep reinforcement learning
with this key budgetary constraint that
they're limited queries to the cloud
that robot must judiciously use so now
I'll actually present this learning
based approach so I'm sure many of you
are familiar with deep reinforcement
learning but I'll give a very simple
example so here you have an agent which
is our offloading policy it's a neural
network that's sitting on the robots GPU
it measures some sensory state s of T
which it uses to guide what is the right
action a of T to use so in our case the
actions are what are the right models to
use at a given time point in order to
control this uncertain environment whose
dynamics are not unknown it initially
and the goal is through interaction and
trial and error you want to optimize or
the performance so you want to maximize
this control performance metric which is
your reward R of T so why am I actually
using RL in this problem well it turns
out RL works quite well and problems
where they're key exploration versus
exploitation trade-offs and it's
actually inherent to this problem so I
want to exploit my own robot computation
as much as possible but I also don't
want to miss out on what the cloud will
tell me how good will a cloud base
result be I can't analytically model
that but I can I can learn that through
interaction and learning during a
training phase
the second reason is again it's very
hard to model that the dynamics of the
system both of the wireless link but
also of the video okay so at this point
I'll show how you can build this
offloading policy which is an RL net
agent that's 18 times smaller than
mobile net it takes in some time some
state s of T it has a very simple action
space
ideally pass robot or cloud predictions
action 0 or 1 if you're nominally
uncertain query your pre-trained mobile
net you're highly uncertain creative
cloud and you tune this decision-making
procedure using a reward function that
trades up accuracy with inference
latency so I'll set this up as a Markov
decision process or an MVP because it's
an optimal control problem so I'll go
through the state's actions rewards and
dynamics in detail so the first question
of interest is what are the robot and
cloud models so we actually choose
separate separate and modular robot
cloud models that don't necessarily need
to be neural nets all they are are
machine learning models with the
different trade-off between model
complexity and inference latency and
they take a new image X of T and map it
to a set of bounding boxes or
predictions and confidences and the
benefit of modularity is actually quite
clear so if the network times out I'm
not stuck I can always default to local
computation and the goal is to have
general machine learning paradigms ok so
I describe the action space before but
it's actually quite intuitive it ranges
from simple past predictions to all the
way to query in the cloud and by virtue
of having four very succinct actions you
can build a small offloading neural net
that is can that can be run in real time
on hardware and of course at the network
times out you can stick to local
computation so the main question is
given these robot and cloud models how
do I actually figure out which is the
right one to use
so that governs our state space which
informs this decision-making procedure
so this might seem like a somewhat
complex equation but actually there are
only four underlying concepts that are
very similar so first I need to know how
much has a visual input changed over
time so I can take the difference
between two frames of video sum that
pixel difference and if most of the
background is black like I showed before
then that's a scalar proxy for dynamism
so if the video is not changing much
then I want to ideally use past
predictions but I need to store my
memory so the next two elements are what
do stored or past prediction stay ok so
not only do I need to know what the past
predictions were I need to know how old
or stale there could be so those are the
time lags which are the next two
components and then finally if I'm
highly uncertain and I want to create a
cloud I need to know what budget remains
and how long I have to allocate this in
order to figure out what is the right
use of cloud computing at a given
operating condition and that's it so
notice here the state space doesn't
actually peek into a new frame of video
that's actually delegated to this
pre-trade neural net so by having a very
small state in action space you can
build this very concise RL agent that
can be run in hardware with minimal
overhead ok so again the goal of this
decision-making procedure is I want to
maximize accuracy but at the same time
minimize system's cost so what are these
systems costs well you can actually
rigorously define them from experiments
based on your own operating conditions
and your own platform so I showed this
table before that trades off the
inference time of a neural net and its
size so you could say roughly if I'm
queering the cloud then maybe due to the
round-trip time the slower inference
time action 3 of putting the cloud is 15
times more expensive than a simply
simple memory lookup and you can tune
this across various platforms based on
your robot ok so at this point I've set
up this MDP let's actually move into
Hardware experiments on a actual
platform so we this is a general
algorithm but we tested it out on
streaming face recognition
from video so you can create a bunch of
synthetic videos millions of them in
fact by splicing together different
phases of interest train your our RL
agent and fine-tune it on real videos so
how might this go well a face will show
up for some time there's some coherence
pattern you may see someone new and then
for the robot model you'll use face net
it's a de facto neural net for face
recognition that's present in all your
iPhone's and then if you're highly
uncertain only then would you query the
club and the process repeats so I can
train this RL agent and simulation
fine-tune it on an actual platform and
deploy it on new videos so these are our
experimental results the RL agent in
blue is running on an NVIDIA GPU and
each episode here is one of 500 test
episodes over real wireless links and
this is the performance so what do I
actually care for in this problem well I
want to maximize my reward namely I want
to maximize accuracy which is on the
y-axis but at the same time minimized
systems cost which is on your x-axis so
in green you see an upper bound solution
so this is an Oracle we're at the robot
if you perfectly knew what the cloud
would say but also perfectly what the
robot would see in the future there's no
uncertainty so this is the best you can
do well you can see the RL agent is
quite close to that but more importantly
it beats by over two times benchmarks in
gray that you would use in robotics
today so today you might say I don't
care about cloud computing and robotics
so I would take perhaps a lower accuracy
but a very low latency a lower systems
cost or you could say maybe I want to
query the cloud but I'll think of a
simple heuristic I don't care about RL
so any time I'm less than 60 percent
confident on the robot
I'll query the cloud otherwise I'll just
stick with local computation and find
the optimal threshold but this actually
doesn't exploit a key property of video
that there's temporal coherence so I can
leverage past predictions which RL does
and that's why it does so much better
and finally you could say I really want
to query the cloud but let's say I have
a budget of 10% of the time so I can
only query the cloud 10% of the time so
every tenth frame
ping that server and just keep past
predictions intermittently then you'll
get this performance but it turns out RL
is much better because it's intelligent
so it learns when to judiciously pack
inquiries during periods of high
uncertainty and that's why it
interleaves better but local computation
in red and cloud computation in yellow
seamlessly on the same video ok so you
can test this out on very small robotic
platforms but it generally works quite
well and you can build this compact RL
off loader and if you want more details
on this you can see our paper with a lot
of marco students so james is the author
on this paper - ok so at this point I'll
switch tracks and actually go much
faster in a very simple problem on
distributed learning and it directly
builds upon real-time computer vision
which is the first time so if I'm
already uncertain and sending image
interesting images to the cloud can I
not actually exploit those to retrain a
model so I mitigate this uncertainty
later with a better model so it's fairly
intuitive that learning rare events can
actually improve your decision-making
models in robotics so if I know that
there's an abrupt construction site
maybe I can think about robotic ways
that automatically update updates HD
maps or signals this to other robots or
I may see a new novel visual event that
I should maybe retrain my net on but the
key inside of our work is to actually
view today's robots as distributed but
passive collectors of training data so
there's a lot of work on active
perception and robotics where should the
robot move next to maximize information
gain but let's say I have a fleet of
Tesla's and I have volunteers which we
actually do it at Stanford maybe I have
no control about where the person is
driving but let's say they see something
new maybe if every Tesla sent 1% of
interesting images it's all per day I
can crowdsource
interesting visual information from
field robots the main idea of using just
1% is by virtue of intelligent sampling
I minimize how much I upload perhaps
when the Tesla is charging at night
how much I store how much I annotate and
recompute on and this minimizes
end-to-end systems bottlenecks and you
can think of many other examples why
this may be useful
Mars roll robots robots where the
network is actually a big problem you
can think of how they prioritize
interesting fuel data and in this part
of the talk I'll actually mirror the
first half quite similarly so what is
the benefit of using the cloud do I
actually need to use the cloud to
specialize these models what what cost
does it come and how can I build a
sampling logic that can run on hardware
that gives you the benefits of both with
minimal costs right so the first
question of interest is why should I
even specialized computer vision models
our default computer computer vision
models not good enough well this is a
picture from my commute near the dish
again so you can see here this image was
run through cocoa cocoa pre-trained
model so I downloaded it from Google and
it's trained on the common objects in
context vocabulary so this can recognize
yet everything from a toothbrush to an
apple but doesn't quite know what a
traffic cone is so it makes a mistake
and calls it a person and in fact this
excavator here is neither like a bus nor
a car so it's totally missed but you can
see this is our retrain model that with
very little cost corrects these errors
okay so we can actually make this more
precise so if you watch this video
you'll notice that a default model on
the left it makes a mistake and calls
every single traffic cone present a
person so you can see this for all of
these right and you can see our retread
model is more domain specific and
specialized but it actually corrects all
these errors so the second reason why
you want to retrain models is that the
real world is constantly changing and I
want robots to crowdsource this
information so on day one at Stanford
they're excavating the road so you can
see that there's a big tractor that's
digging up the soil but there's a lot of
real-time model
that you can see so at the right panel
within a couple of weeks they're totally
different trucks they're actually
filling in the road using this asphalt
compactor and actually a human is
filling in part of it but on my commute
you also see various interesting
patterns so I may pass by Google and
I'll see a way no car and no neural net
today can recognize way more cars or
lidar units
publicly at least but with little data
you can do this this is our custom model
but then the real world changes so I may
not see the wave world car but on
highway 85 I'll see yet another startup
self-driving car so the point of this is
the real world is changing and can we
not have robots reflect this you can
think of very different different
applications robotic ways for example so
clearly there's some benefit in
retraining our computer vision models in
the cloud but at what cost does it come
right so the main cost is actually
annotation so I had a very small data
set from my own dash cam clips but still
computationally they're over right now
five hundred thousand images to
automatically mind so you might ask why
don't I just randomly select 1% of this
data well it turns out it's still very
expensive to label we paid the Google
Cloud labeling service to do this
because it was just too much for us to
do and you can see this is one image
that Google labeled for me and it has
over 20 bounding boxes so if you do the
numbers at this rate this is exorbitant
it's not feasible in a research budget
but if you do this for autonomous cars
it's several hundreds of thousands of
dollars per month or even millions and
to end costs we've actually talked to
several startups that are facing a cute
cloud computing costs which are kind of
intuitive unintuitive in robotics so
I'll show how you can actually do this
on free credits for about $400 by
automatically sampling but intelligently
so the key question is how might I
actually do that right so the first idea
or may of interest is that you may
actually need very few or minimal images
so on the y-axis is the final accuracy
of a machine learning model and on the
x-axis is how much data that I use to
train this neural net
but what you can see is that there's a
key law of diminishing returns for most
static visual concepts so what I mean by
that is maybe to learn what the way male
car is I just need 10% of data and after
some time the marginal gains and
accuracy are outweighed by the high
systems costs of going out into the
field and acquiring these samples but as
I showed before for these dynamic
targets which are constantly changing
maybe you need quite a lot of data like
the construction sites and again you can
think of examples or robots crowdsource
this in an automated way so the second
question of interest is given that
perhaps I only need 10% of visual data
how can I automatically select this from
a neural net sitting on board a drone or
robot right so the key idea here is I
can use transfer learning so I can get a
pre trained neural net from Google it
may recognize toothbrushes and such but
it can be augmented to learn new classes
with a few examples of way mow cars or
lidar units okay so I can train this
neural net with an augmented vocabulary
to recognize these new visual concepts
and then when I train this net I can
build a data-driven filter so the output
of this net is a softmax probability
which is saying what is a confidence
score for being a way more car in red so
I look at all my way mow cars that are
actual women cars in red and say what is
the confidence there often is an
empirical cut off between background
noise so in blue are irrelevant images
different types of cars or flowers for
example so you can maybe build some
proxy of maybe this looks like a lame-o
car or you can use embedding distances
so embeddings are compact visual
descriptors their intermediate layers
have a neural net and often empirically
you can see the distance between two
flowers may be much lower than a flower
and a car for example so this can kind
of help me signal whether there's some
signal of interest from background noise
of millions of images the key idea here
is you actually get embeddings and these
confidences scores for free during
inference
so just by running then you're on there
I get these simple numbers I can do
comparisons and kind of crowdsource or
select what data I care for so this may
be a little confusing and I'll make it
more clear on the next slide right so
our learning happens in days or rounds I
so at the start maybe some human in the
cloud looks at this video and says hey I
don't know traffic cone so well maybe I
need more pictures of construction sites
hey robotic fleet of tesla's find me
more such examples so you actually send
a limited amount of these images to your
cars
but not only that you train a new neural
network with the Augmented label saying
I have a few examples of way more cards
that I can scrape online let me send you
a neural net trained on those two
nominally recognize them and by virtue
of training this net I can build a
filter that differentiates signal in red
from background noise in blue and you
send these thresholds to the robot then
the robot is tasked with a very simple
and easy problem given this new neural
net and a set of target images it may
see some new video and it says hey does
this sort of look like a way mow car if
so I can if so if it passes a threshold
then I can save it onboard upload it at
the end of the night and interestingly
there's a human in the loop that looks
at these filtered prioritized examples
retrains the neural network and syncs it
back to the robot and if you do this
over several days on day one you might
be quite uncertain about what do you
actually care for from noise but as you
accrue more data and use feedback from a
human in the loop you do much better so
the key notion of cloud feedback here so
I don't have time to go through the full
paper but it's about this intelligent
sampling logic that can actually fit on
a USB stick so imagine you actually send
them to volunteers that you're doing so
let's actually get into the results so
our system is called harvest net it's in
orange because we're trying to harvest
interesting information to retrain a
neural network and what do you care
about in this problem
you want to maximize accuracy in the
fewest amount of days
so every single one of these sampling
schemes are extremely cash limited so
they only upload 200 images per night so
you can think of random schemes that
aren't so good but our system does
fairly well compared to an Oracle that
has no uncertainty the key idea here is
by using feedback from a human and by
adjusting these thresholds I do met much
better than non adaptive schemes but
send very little data that minimizes
your end-to-end systems cost okay so
these are more examples of this so
currently we're actually trying to build
this out on very simple home robotics
platforms so we have a team of what's
called federated Roombas some at UCSD
some here at Stanford and the idea is
you can have on HTTP you running
real-time inference and prioritizing
interesting data so this is actually a
picture for my home and you can see
default models work fairly well for a
bit and then they totally break apart on
as a rumor moves around so imagine every
room bought and every house could send
10% of interesting data there are also
privacy questions you can just like I
built a neural net that selectively
uploads data I can build a neural net
that throws away any pictures of a human
being in any of these okay so we're
doing this with Tesla Tesla dash cam
data as well and if any of you have a
test son want to volunteer that would be
great okay so at this point I'm almost
done so I'll finish very quickly on
future directions so this is my desk in
gates and you can see here this is the
computer vision first part of this talk
was done in this large bulky GPU and now
it's just a USB stick so clearly
embedded AI is getting faster cheaper
and more power efficient so you might
ask why do I need why do I even care
about cloud computing well the cloud
will always have a role you can collate
or data from several robots at a time
you can use human labeling services you
can retrain models and finally you can
use precomputed databases that simply
won't fit on board your drone or this
really small USB stick so there's
interesting contention about what I
should do on the robot and watch I do in
the cloud and that was the whole premise
of this research ok the next question is
how should we design video streaming if
we know that
you will never watch this video but
maybe a deep neural net sitting in the
cloud ideally I could send much less
over-the-air and get the same sensing
task accuracy by Co designing the way I
represent data with the downstream tasks
so for those who are interested in a
little bit more theoretical machine
learning here are some very simple but
preliminary results so I can say let me
take a new image X of T compress it
aggressively to send over a wireless
link and then decode it
okay so typical machine learning would
stop here you would say I care about how
good the reconstruction loss is but
perhaps I don't care about a faithful
reconstruction I care about how good
that image is for downstream control or
maybe even inference so I can plus push
the loss function to the right and by
fixing this neural net and Co designing
the - you can see you can be very
aggressive in compression so you can
send much less over-the-air so these are
just very small examples from M NIST and
get very high compression ratios the
next question is embedded ai is getting
better so imagine robots that are
severely network limited maybe on Mars
or undersea or in mines DARPA has a
subterranean challenge for example if
embedded AI is getting better they
measure a lot of data data maybe they
can retrain models on device so this is
a concept called federated learning but
we have some variants of it because in
federated learning you never actually
leaked private data to a cloud but here
a robot if it's in certain needs to
sometimes send data so how can we send
safe data retrain models on device with
minimal interaction with the human and
finally there problems in network
control are cost data boundaries so
today I limited how much data I send
purely because of network bandwidth
utilization problems I actually worked
at a start-up so imagine if AT&T gets a
lot of interesting Network data we were
doing downstream control so you might
ask how do I send private forecasts to
say uber for example and limit the scope
and volume of how much data I share
across a private data boundary so these
are all my papers if you're interested
we should definitely talk and this is
it's in this general space of robot
clouding track
cool thanks what were the returns like
yeah so the budget is the robot has a
budget about how many times you can
query the cloud ranging from say five
percent of the time up to fifty so these
are emulating different wireless link
conditions I trained the RL agent on a
wide variety of budgets and actually
tested that's why Paul had a
distribution on returns because there
some research shows yeah so definitely
cloud computing can help in what's
called super resolution so enhancing the
quality of an image what more I was
talking about was on the communication
part so oftentimes in sensing tasks a
lot of the background is irrelevant so
let's say I want to do automated license
plate detection maybe I don't care about
background trees and such so that I can
compress much less but also store less
on a cloud server so there are two
facets of it one is super resolution as
you mentioned enhancing which has a role
this is for the communication part like
chinese state media machine 5g yeah and
I've seen them about how it's gonna run
robotics that's not even mobile like
manipulates and stuff could you talk
about how you see 5g affecting the stuff
you've worked yeah yeah that's an
excellent question
so 5g is about massive data rates at low
latency right so here I talked about a
large amount of sensory data but imagine
if I had very low latency or network
delay I can actually do control in the
loop so teleoperation so one thing I
know that people are thinking about in
China is like manufacturing floors where
Wi-Fi is a limited commodity it's there
are tons of robots
humans using Wi-Fi on the manufacturing
floor you may have small room but like
things doing logistics we have a central
server so imagine if you can tell your
operate these robots but also the notion
of a cloud could be a human has who has
abstract bandwidth to query the robot
there's machine to machine protocols and
5g so 5g will just enhance everything
here I hope